Mr and Mrs Clooney my goodness you
brought out the sparkle
so there's so much to be celebrating
tonight you brought out the Sparkles
congratulations on your Kennedy Center
Honor we've got two Oscars five Golden
Globes four SAG Awards and now a Kennedy
Center Honor where does this honor rank
amongst the rest well I kind of hate to
rank them it's like you know picking
your favorite kid but I have to say uh
it's a really beautiful honor it's such
a fun thing I've never I've never been
to the honors before and what a fun
weekend it's been we had a great time we
were at the White House and we had a
really wonderful time at the state
department last night so it's a it was
actually very emotional it's fun to be
around people who are also friends of
yours who are receiving this it was fun
I like that you say emotional Amal I
know you are one to give an unbelievable
speech are you speaking tonight
um I'm not speaking um I've been
listening to amazing speeches all
weekend and I've been in tears for much
of it um but it's been really lovely the
White House was Christmasy and you know
when I go to the state department I'm
usually working so it was nice to be in
a lovely ballroom and celebrating George
and all the other amazing honorees
watching the two of you not only your
contributions to the world of
entertainment but what you do with the
Clooney Foundation how you lead by
example with parenting even though there
are a few pranks in there you know when
you when your kids see that you're
winning a Kennedy Center tonight when
your kids see all the incredible work
that you do what is it that you hope
they remember most and take away from
the example the two of you believe
well we just hope we raise nice kids who
care about people and and put other
people ahead of themselves you know it's
it's the same thing we've we're both
raised at which is if to whom a lot is
given a lot is expected and so we're
going to expect a lot from our children
I know there are a lot of pranks in the
Clooney household and with the holidays
right around the corner with the
holidays right around the corner uh what
do the holidays in the Clooney household
look like
well there's a lot of usually we're in
England Around The Christmas Tree there
this year we're going away on holiday
somewhere warm so but they'll be right
now there's a tree in the house and
there's a lot of like there's a train
set coming so that'll be fun yeah if I
ever get it put together because that's
the hard part is that the thing that you
task him with putting together the kids
toys we both try and often fail yeah
we're trying to teach them perseverance
so we can't give up
my final question the last time we spoke
with you George you said that the kids
are actually smarter than you yeah I'm
dying to know what mall's response to
that do you agree I think they're both
smarter than both of us yes they've
certainly outsmarted us so and they have
a language that they speak that we don't
speak a distinct disadvantage yeah in
French she speaks French so they've got
me they've got me coming and going I
don't know what is the best prank
they've pulled on you lately
um they have some jokes that have been
playing which they're so filthy I'm not
even allowed to tell you five years old
and telling filthy jokes I'm all what do
you make of them whose contribution do
you think this is my wife is Bill see
[Music]